valérie benaïm oui il paraît que vous
avez un os à dire oui moi je voudrais
vous demande vous demander pardon à vous
sert il parce que on a une relation tous
les deux on est très très proche entre
voulais demander pardon rien vous à moi
oui mais qu'est ce que vous m'avez fait
pas si je vais vous expliquer parce que
d'abord tu dis pas je suis conne mais
parce qu'on s'appelle tout le temps oui
si on vous connaît énormément de choses
l'un sur l'autre et donc on a des
dossiers évidemment main sur l'autre et
moi je suis ce qui m'arrive depuis huit
ans et que un peu insolente avec vous
parce que je sais des choses et donc je
dis des trucs à l'antenne je vous
titille je vous dis je
voilà donc voudrais vous demander pardon
tenez pas pardon pour un truc que vous
m'avez fait non pour un truc que je vais
vous faire maintenant
attendez donc par avance à yahia qui va
sortir cette émission c'est le travail
qui est d'ailleurs je mesure utile et on
va pas rendre l'antenne à ne pas leur
dire c'est que voilà maintenant benaï
attendait parfois gelés trop loin nord
beinheim en faisant tout depuis début
avril dit mois exactement ce qui se
passe quelle est cette histoire mais
écoutez vous savez qu'on sait beaucoup
de choses on s'appelle tous les jours on
se parle on connaît nos vies et c'est
donc j'ai des dossiers gdg des infos
j'ai des photos j'ai des filles mais
j'ai des trucs ça voilà j'ai et etsi et
je suis un peu insolente
oui et donc je vais être encore
insolente une fois de plus je vais
demander pardon pour cette insolence
donc qu'est ce que vous avez comme
dossiers sont
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi il faut une explication pour
expliquer ya très longtemps et je crois
que j'étais fort boyard
j'avais fait fort boyard et la nuit je
m'étais mis coutu à poil et j'avais
déambuler dans le fort à 9 ans tu en
voilà mais avec un sac à dos et j'avais
fait pipi duo du fort ça et on kiffe et
donc j'avais réveiller tout le monde
voilà tous les gars et comment vous avez
pu vous procurer d'autres photos mails
écouter on est très proches vous et moi
et je ne vais pas pou cave et la
personne qui m'a donné cette photo qui
est qui est un intime et donc c'était
bien cette photo de fort boyard et je ne
me trompe pas exactement
donc c'est quand je me suis bien poil de
m'excuser d'avoir dévoilé une fois de
plus des choses devant je vais appeler
public a besoin savoir il est en toute
transparence et je sais qu'on sait déjà
je ne joue pas je ne vous pardonne pas
non mais merci merci quand même
surprenant c'est que vous ayez cacher le
service trois pièces
voilà c'était ça c'est raté mais c'est
ça c'est ça